alors bonjour à toutes et à tous et
bienvenue pour cette table ronde autour
du pacte social je suis Alice lemoal
adjointe au maire de Clichy élu dans les
Hauts-de-Seine et du départemental et
secrétaire général adjointe au Modem et
j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir ce matin 4
invités de marque pour évoquer avec nous
les enjeux de solidarité et du pacte
social mais avant tout cela on va
regarder une petite vidéo puis
j'introduirai la séquence et
présenterait nos invités alors si la
régie peut lancer le micro-trottoir
merci
qu'est-ce que ça représente pour vous le
modèle social français
pour moi c'est le modèle social français
ça devrait être ça et comme c'est un peu
parti avec le déficit qui peut y avoir
au niveau budgétaire le nombre quand
même de fonctionnaires alors c'est sûr
qu'il faut faire tourner la machine mais
on finit par se demander à qui et
pourquoi on paye nos impôts
si vraiment je une réponse synthétique
pas grand chose ça fait pas grand chose
pour en tout cas je parle pour moi
après globalement je tousse des aPL et
c'est tout ce qui me permet de vivre et
mes parents je serais juste
pas la rue mais en tout cas
voilà quoi
est-ce que vous êtes attaché
oui
et
c'est par rapport au modèle social
français est-ce que vous y êtes attaché
ouais qu'est-ce que ça représente pour
vous
je pense que c'est un des fondement de
la France après j'ai pas toujours
d'accord et comment il fonctionne mais
pour moi il est important parce que
c'est comme ça que la France est
construit
un micro-trottoir sur le modèle social
français pour introduire
cette séquence alors qui dit pacte
social
un bref exercice de définition des
termes je suis allé voir dans Larousse
la définition de pacte à corps
solennelle conclue entre deux personnes
pour Rousseau dans son ouvrage du
contrat social impact c'est trouver une
forme d'association par laquelle chacun
s'unissant à tous n'obéissent pourtant
qu'à lui-même et reste aussi libre
qu'auparavant alors ça c'est juste
une brève définition et donc le pacte
social c'est un enjeu de solidarité qui
se joue entre les générations entre ceux
qui ont un travail et ceux qui n'en ont
pas entre ceux qui sont en retraite et
ceux qui ont un travail entre les
Français et ceux qui veulent vivre chez
nous entre ceux qui sont en fin de vie
et ceux qui restent en vie et les
accompagnent entre les enfants et leurs
parents c'était aussi un impact entre
les territoires ruraux ou urbains riches
ou appauvris
impact aussi entre nos territoires
métropolitains ou ultramarins bref dans
tous les pans de la société et dans tout
nos territoires nous sommes concernés
pour en parler ce matin j'ai donc le
plaisir d'accueillir quatre personnes
alors je commence par vous présenter
Jean-Christophe con ministre des
Solidarités de l'autonomie et des
personnes handicapées
qui m'a fait la confidence d'être sous
votre contrôle passé chez les jeunes
centrists il y a un petit moment
et voilà dans plusieurs cabinets
politiques et vous êtes vous avez été
ensuite directeur de la Croix Rouge
Française j'accueille également internet
de Louviers vice-présidente du conseil
départemental de l'Eure en charge des
solidarités que vous connaissez tous
elle est également secrétaire général
adjointe au modem Hervé Bonamy vous êtes
vice-président du Secours Catholique
président de la délégation de
Loire-Atlantique et vous y tenez puisque
c'est votre ancrage votre lieu de
ressourcement et votre moteur pour
l'action et Perrine Goulet tu es député
MoDem de la Nièvre spécialiste des
questions d'enfance et d'enfance en
danger tu as remis sous le précédent
quinquennat un rapport à l'Assemblée
nationale sur ces questions voilà ce qui
nous permettra avec nos quatre invités
de de d'aborder un certain nombre de
sujets mais pour démarrer donc je vais
laisser à chacun un propos liminaire qui
va voilà permettre de planter le décor
et puis ensuite on fera une séquence la
plus interactive possible alors Monsieur
le Ministre la parole à vous pour 4
minutes c'est un exercice contraint mais
vous allez vous en sortir à merveille
très bien mais écoutez bonjour à tous Je
vous confirme que je suis ravi d'être
avec vous ce matin effectivement parce
que il y a 20 ans j'ai commencé mon
engagement politique avec les centristes
à l'UDF donc voilà c'est en quelques en
quelques sortes un retour aux sources
comme vous le voyez j'ai une voix qui
est un peu cassée je crois que le la
menthe du Mojito a eu raison de mes
cordes vocales hier soir donc je vous
prie de bien vouloir m'en excuser
néanmoins j'ai passé un agréable moment
à vos côtés hier soir aussi vous dire
effectivement que je suis ministre des
Solidarités de l'autonomie et des
personnes handicapées un portefeuille
qui est au cœur de ce pacte social je
crois qu'il est important c'est le
ministère de toutes les vulnérabilités
ces ministère des solidarités concrètes
du premier jour au dernier jour de la
vie avec au milieu la nécessité pour moi
de faire en sorte que ce pacte social
que ce modèle social y soit le plus
efficace possible et je crois que comme
on l'a entendu avec les micro-trottoirs
il y a un certain nombre de travaux
aujourd'hui à effectuer pour améliorer
ce système de protection sociale et puis
travailler aussi à l'inclusivité de
notre société c'est au cœur là aussi de
mes missions et de mon portefeuille j'ai
trois objectifs
principaux derrière cette feuille de
route la première c'est de faire en
sorte que notre modèle social il
répondent aux besoins sociaux
d'aujourd'hui dire voilà on l'actualise
de façon permanente on l'adapte aux
besoins sociaux c'est la réalité
aujourd'hui que connaisse les familles
monoparentales par exemple de notre pays
il faut savoir que 30% de ces familles
monoparentales vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté c'est une urgence c'est c'est
le vieillissement de la population la
transition démographique à laquelle on
doit faire face dans d'ici à 2030 en
2030 un tiers de la population française
aura plus de 60 ans c'est aussi
l'extrême pauvreté on en parle peu et
c'est un sujet que je souhaite remettre
vraiment au coeur de de ma feuille de
route ça c'est le premier objectif
c'est répondre à ses besoins sociaux le
deuxième c'est réduire les inégalités au
sein de notre pays réduire les
inégalités de destin continuer à
investir dans nos politiques sociales
pour faire en sorte que et bien on
favorise l'égalité des chances de notre
pays vous savez qu'il faut si
générations pour sortir sortir de la
pauvreté
il y a quelque chose qui fonctionne pas
dans notre modèle et il faut
impérativement l'améliorer c'est aussi
tout au long de la vie lutter contre
toutes les assignations qui sont liées à
ces vulnérabilités que ce soit le
handicap la perte d'autonomie l'enfance
la précarité et donc lutter contre
contre ces assignations et puis le
dernier objectif c'est celui aussi et
bien de rendre ce système le plus
incitatif possible à la reprise du
travail parce que je crois que offrir un
travail à une personne qui en est exclu
c'est lui rendre de l'autonomie et de la
dignité et je crois profondément qu'il y
a pas d'un côté l'économie et de l'autre
côté l'état social je crois que pour que
l'un soit performant l'autre doit aussi
être efficace et puis il y en a ça nous
aura pas échappé qui finance l'autre et
donc tout est lié et il faut surtout pas
opposer dans notre système c'est ces
deux volants de notre pacte social
je dirais également deux choses enfin je
dois répondre à deux d'urgences
aujourd'hui il faut bien l'avoir en tête
celle de protéger les Français les plus
vulnérables face à des crises qu'elles
soient économiques sociales liée à un
contexte géopolitique qui est ce qu'il
est aujourd'hui notamment les protéger
aussi face à des événements climatiques
graves on en a parlé tout à l'heure au
regard de ce qui s'est passé cet été
mais la deuxième urgence c'est aussi
d'accompagner les Français et en
particulier les plus vulnérables d'entre
eux dans les grandes transitions que
notre pays doit affronter que soit la
transition écologique démographique ou
sociale et puis dernier point j'ai déjà
été trop long je le sais il y a deux
conditions pour que ça fonctionne en
tout cas je mets ça dans le débat et je
pense qu'on en parlera d'autres mais à
deux qui sont particulièrement
importantes pour moi la première c'est
des ressources humaines c'est-à-dire que
c'est politique publique elles sont
portées par des femmes par des hommes
qui sont engagés au quotidien pour les
construire et pour les mettre en oeuvre
vous savez qu'il y a un gros problème
d'attractivité des métiers dans les dans
le dans le domaine du soin de
l'accompagnement de l'éducation et donc
il faut vraiment qu'on travaille cette
question de façon prioritaire si on veut
que
et bien notre modèle social il puisse
fonctionner et puis le deuxième c'est la
question de la confiance notre modèle
social aujourd'hui il connaît une crise
de confiance parce que il est jugé
parfois injuste parfois inefficace parce
que on a tous été sensible
malheureusement à tous les drames qui
sont survenus dernièrement dans des
établissements médico-sociaux dans les
EHPAD dans les crèches et donc il faut
ramener aujourd'hui impérativement la
confiance dans ce système si on veut que
ce pacte social tienne voilà ce que je
voulais vous dire en introduction merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre alors je
vais passer la parole à Internet et Luc
local qui elle aussi va pouvoir
nous faire quelques mots d'introduction
Anne me permet de préciser que tu as au
cours de ton ta première année de mandat
au conseil départemental de leur conduit
des Assises de la solidarité dont tu vas
probablement pouvoir nous parler un
petit peu sur le fond la forme la
méthode voilà c'est à toi merci Alice
oui revenir un peu sur cette première
année de mandat donc c'est pas mon
premier c'est mon premier mandat au
département
voilà ce que je peux dire un début de
mandat passionnant parce que le
président qui est aussi ministre
Sébastien Lecornu m'a confié le pilotage
de ses assises justement pour faire le
point sur nos politiques publiques et la
manière de les conduire à l'aune de ces
grandes transitions donc
climatique numérique et dans le contexte
de crise sanitaire que nous avons connue
donc c'était absolument passionnant
c'est absolument passionnant parce que
je suis encore dedans de commencer comme
ça puisque ça permet de faire le point
ça permet d'établir les partenariats ça
permet de concerter et d'avoir du coup
un diagnostic un peu objectif j'ai fait
plusieurs plusieurs j'ai d'abord une
conviction qui est vrai pour le
département mais sûrement vrai à
d'autres strates c'est que ce mandat
sera social où il ne sera pas ça c'est
ma première conviction j'ai constaté de
nombreux paradoxes qui amène à réfléchir
d'abord le premier paradoxe c'est que le
département qui est chef de fil de
l'action sociale et qui consacre en
général c'est vrai dans leur mais c'est
vrai ailleurs les deux tiers de son
budget à cette protection de l'enfance à
l'accompagnement du maintien à domicile
etc quand on fait campagne ce qui était
le cas il y a un an aucun de nos
concitoyens aucun de nos électeurs ne
nous parle de ces 4 millions pour ce qui
est du département de l'Eure mais de ces
deux tiers du budget et de ce qu'on en
fait voilà on nous parle des trous dans
les routes qui est une autre compétence
éventuellement un peu de collège mais on
nous parle pas d'action sociale c'est
quand même un grand paradoxe de se dire
que c'est départements qui sont aussi
des opérateurs de réaction sociale ils
consacrent énormément d'argent et que ça
n'est pas mis au débat quand on fait
campagne ça c'est le premier paradoxe le
deuxième paradoxe c'est c'est que les
Français ne croient plus à la puissance
publique alors dans notre ça a été
d'ailleurs un peu illustré là dans le
micro-trottoir dans nos assises on a
fait des sondages quantitatifs et
qualitatifs pour justement recueillir la
parole des heureuses et des euros et
quand on a posé la question si vous avez
un problème d'ordre social aujourd'hui
vers qui vous tournez vous c'était assez
édifiant j'étais assez stupéfaite par ça
ils disent à 85% d'abord la famille et
les amis et ils disent ensuite si c'est
pas la famille et les amis on se tourne
vers la commune mais le département
jamais jamais cité et les associations
caritatives je suis désolé pour mon
voisin ne sont pas cités non plus donc
on a quand même un petit sujet alors
après quand on creuse globalement ils
nous disent on a honte on a peur et puis
surtout on aura le droit à rien parce
qu'il y a des effets de seuil parce que
parce que pour eux c'est 20 et qu'ils
ont le sentiment qu'ils seront
catalogués et donc ils ne veulent plus
voilà donc il y a la question de la ça
pose la question de la lisibilité de nos
politiques publiques personne ne sait ce
que nous faisons finalement je pense
qu'il faut le dire avec assez de clarté
ça pose la question du non recours au
droit dont on sait qu'il coûte beaucoup
plus cher que la fraude aujourd'hui
et finalement ça amène à une conclusion
on a la meilleure protection sociale du
monde vous l'avez dit c'était un peu dit
d'ailleurs aussi dans le micro-trottoir
quand même heureusement mais on peut le
répéter à l'envie on peut sauter sur nos
chaises c'est un peu comme pour l'Union
européenne qu'est-ce qu'on ferait sans
l'Union européenne finalement ça ne
marque pas les esprits et nos
concitoyens continuent de penser que ils
ne sont pas suffisamment protégés qu'on
ne fait rien pour eux et surtout qu'on
ne résout pas leurs problèmes voilà à
hauteur d'homme ça ne fonctionne pas ce
qui amène d'ailleurs dans un département
comme celui de l'heure cinq
circonscriptions sur la précédente
mandature 5 députés majorités
présidentielles aujourd'hui on en a plus
un 4 RN on n'est pas les seuls et un
Nuxe et on n'est pas les seuls je
discutais beaucoup depuis que je suis
arrivé hier avec les collègues je suis
pas le seul département je tiens à le
dire parce que c'est pas le seul
département à vivre ça donc mais
certainement que Néo français nos
concitoyens ont un vrai pessimisme de
projection et que ces extrêmes
prospèrent sur ce sentiment de de
déclassement et sur ce pessimisme sur
les préoccupations et les attentes
l'emploi n'est plus un sujet aujourd'hui
quand on a fait nos sondages etc tous
les partenariats tous les voilà l'emploi
n'est plus un sujet le sujet majeur
partout alors ça a été vraiment la
campagne mais c'est vrai aussi quand on
sonde nos concitoyens nos habitants le
sujet majeur c'est la santé l'accès aux
soins ça c'est vraiment le sujet de
préoccupation numéro 1 et le pouvoir
d'achat ça a été longuement documenté
notamment par les médias je reviens pas
dessus le deuxième sujet j'ai été
surprise et je sais pas si Sarah est
dans la dans la dans la pièce mais le
deuxième sujet dans l'heure je sais pas
trop mais je pense que c'est assez vrai
pour des
voilà des lieux un peu ruraux c'est la
jeunesse les gens se préoccupent de
savoir ce que leur enfant vont pouvoir
faire où est-ce qu'ils vont pouvoir
étudier qu'elles vont être les débouchés
à ce qu'ils vont trouver un travail et
puis le corollaire c'est du coup le
vieillissement voilà et comment on va
faire pour accompagner nos parents
vieillissants dans le maintien à
domicile mais aussi dans les structures
spécialisées et puis il y a un sujet
mobilité bon pareil je le documente pas
parce qu'il a été largement voilà alors
les enjeux
je m'extrais j'essaye de m'extraire un
peu de mon contact local mais je pense
que c'est un des dénominateurs communs
pour moi il y a un enjeu d'anticipation
de nos politiques publiques et notamment
sur la question de la démographie et de
la dépendance de l'adaptation nos
territoires au vieillissement de la
population on a un énorme sujet et il
faudrait pas que rapidement on se
retrouve dans la même situation
qu'aujourd'hui sur le sujet de la santé
on n'a pas suffisamment anticipé ces
questions de santé
on s'y est pas attaqué suffisamment tôt
le vieillissement de la population c'est
la même chose ça va devenir un sujet
absolument crucial dans le département
de l'Eure on a 300 équivalentes plein de
d'aide à domicile qui sont vacants et
les projections à l'horizon 2030 c'est
qu'ils nous en faudrait 1500 de plus
quasi enfin 1800 on avoisine le besoin
rien que pour les aides à domicile de
2000 postes à moins de 10 ans enfin
c'est-à-dire demain hier en fait donc
comme on va gérer ça comme on gère le
logement comment on gère le parcours
résidentiel de la personne âgée donc
anticipation ça me permet ça pousse bien
sûr la question des métiers en tension
que vous avez déjà évoqué après il y a
un gros enjeu de méthode
relation partenariat alors notamment la
relation est à collectivité et je pose
un sujet est-ce que les départements ne
sont que des opérateurs de l'État voilà
parce que quand même on a quelques
obligations et ça n'est finalement pas
simple de trouver le d'avoir le pouvoir
d'agir le pouvoir de décision pour des
élus départementaux c'est quand même
assez compliqué mais une fois que j'ai
dit ça je le dis aussi pour nous parce
que c'est important de voir la poutre
qui est dans notre œil aussi parce que
finalement on agit aussi un peu de la
même manière avec nos acteurs locaux qui
sont aussi des opérateurs des
départements et donc là la question se
pose et j'ai été stupéfaite dans les
assises de constater que finalement nos
acteurs associatifs pour la plupart ne
demandent pas tant d'argent
supplémentaire que le discours de la
méthode voilà comment on fait pour
travailler ensemble avec beaucoup plus
de simplification la confiance vous avez
raison c'est un vrai sujet et voilà et
donc la méthode et peut-être juste un
sujet je voudrais juste évoquer le la
philosophie du travail social et
peut-être le changement de paradigme
qu'on a à mener parce que c'est un
changement de méthode il y a la question
de maintenant je préfère les appeler les
acteurs accompagnés voilà comment on
fait pour redonner du pouvoir d'agir
alors c'est un peu en cours mais il y a
besoin d'améliorer ça acteur accompagné
ça devrait être quelque chose
d'important et le ministre de la Santé
en a parlé aussi la prévention on est
très souvent dans des logiques de
réparation soyons davantage dans la dans
la prévention voilà c'est extrêmement
important j'ai dépassé des eaux merci à
nous pourtant mais parce que tu es
passionné merci Anne pour ton premier
propos introductif alors avant de passer
la parole à Hervé Bonamy que j'ai
présenté tout à l'heure je vais demander
à la Régie si vous voulez bien mettre la
petite vidéo de dater des carmonde on a
souhaité faire entendre la voix de Marie
à laggrave que vous connaissez peut-être
voilà donc je laisse la régie lancer la
vidéo sur la question de la grande
pauvreté
à tes déclare monde agir tous pour la
dignité car monde nous sommes un
mouvement de personnes d'horizon
extrêmement divers qui s'unissent pour
éradiquer la grande pauvreté et nous
expérimentons dans les différents
domaines des droits fondamentaux les
possibles pour éradiquer la grande
pauvreté je souhaite vous laisser un
message aujourd'hui je souhaite vous
dire que les personnes qui sont au RSA
dans notre pays il y en a 30% qui ne le
demande pas parce que la manière de
demander ce RSA est beaucoup trop
intrusive avec le RSA on ne vit pas on
survit dans notre pays sachez que les
personnes qui sont au RSA ont 497 euros
pour vivre une fois la location la
location logement enlevée mais avec ces
80 497 euros comment font-ils pour vivre
c'est impossible je vous invite à faire
confiance au plus pauvres à comprendre
que nous devons faire société ensemble
je vous remercie
voilà c'est bref mes percutant merci à
elle pour son message et donc je passe
la parole à Hervé Bonamy pour lui aussi
si vous pouvez partager avec nous les
les constats que vous vous faites au
Secours catholique et les solutions que
vous que vous proposez pour voilà
consolider notre pacte social merci
merci d'avoir pour votre accueil à vous
tous et à vous toutes
les années précédentes je pense que vous
aviez l'habitude de voir Véronique Fayet
qui est que vous connaissez bien puisque
elle est une des vôtres
cette année c'est moi la véronique est
actuellement au Mans avec le LCC merci
et je quand j'entends le message d'ATD
on travaille d'ailleurs en total de
proximité avec ATD je crois qu'il y a
déjà beaucoup de choses dedites alors je
vais pas revenir sur la lecture que l'on
fait de la pauvreté parce que j'ai 4
minutes en revanche je voudrais vous
donner un peu la vision que l'on a au
niveau du Secours Catholique c'est une
qui est une association avec 65
000 bénévoles sur sur l'ensemble du
territoire mille salariés et nous et
nous accompagnons environ un million de
situations familiales par an et donc
nous avons depuis 76 ans maintenant une
vue qui nous permet de pouvoir porter
une parole ou qui qui
s'entre dans la réalité des territoires
et dans dans le cas échéant dans la
grande pauvreté que je souhaiterais
aborder avec vous ce matin alors lutter
contre les causes de pauvreté
d'inégalités d'exclusion et voir si
éventuellement on peut proposer nos
acteurs acteurs associatifs de quelques
alternatives alors pour nous au niveau
du conseil d'un enfant au niveau du
Secours Catholique que nous voyons cinq
thèmes importants l'accès au travail et
à des revenus dignes l'accès digne
alimentation durable l'accès à
l'hébergement et au logement l'accueil
et l'intégration
des étrangers et la transition
écologique juste
s'ouvre actuellement un nouveau
quinquennat c'est aussi l'occasion de
d'interpeller les les élus et
particulièrement les ministres cette
dimension politique de l'attraction nous
amène donc à vous partager trois points
de vigilance important pour nous les
associations caritatives bien au-delà de
la du Secours Catholique et
en ce début de prise de parole soyons
attentifs à ne pas nous laisser envahir
par des idéologies de l'extrême qui
manient les peurs comme ça peut être
indiqué donc attention à ne pas de
souffler sur les braises de la division
et de la stigmatisation en alimentant
l'idée que la pauvreté tout compte fait
serait un choix des personnes
ou alors un discours tendant à faire
croire que les personnes migrantes sont
responsables de tous les problèmes de
notre pays c'est quelque chose qui court
cette peur que systématiquement
on redit on redéploie cette
stigmatisation ça fait des dégâts
énormes auprès de la grande pauvreté
soyons plutôt dans une posture de
recherche de la cohésion sociale et
promouvoir les capacités de personnes en
situation de pauvreté précarité des
personnes migrantes
notre deuxième point de vigilance c'est
que le sort des plus pauvres ne sorte
pas des radars de la vie politique et
des priorités sociales les plus pauvres
ce sont les sans voix
ce que l'on n'entend pas la personne que
l'on voit sur le bord de la route et
dont on évite le regard
c'est le qui mendit les enfants qui
dorment dans la rue voilà et cela trop
souvent on passe à côté sans vouloir les
voir et quand je dis on ça peut aussi
nous arriver à nous pourtant alors que
nous baignons totalement dans dans ce
milieu là
donc l'éradication de la courbe grande
pauvreté et l'objectif du Millénaire
pour le Développement numéro un objectif
que la France est donnée devant l'ONU à
atteindre d'ici 2030 2030
ça sera peu d'année après ce quinquennat
donc c'est vraiment un sujet d'actualité
et il faut qu'on soit tous très
ambitieux par rapport à ça
nos demandes à nous au niveau du Secours
Catholique pour permettre aux ménage de
sortir la tête de l'eau sont constantes
avec un neurollement un élargissement
des minima sociaux notre collègue de la
télé
on a parlé que pouvons-nous faire avec
500 euros avec 500 euros vous pouvez pas
demander à une famille en même temps de
se mettre en débarge de retrouver un
emploi son quotidien c'est arrivé à
trouver la nourriture payer des
consommables et essayer de mettre
parfois de l'essence dans la voiture
pour pouvoir pour pouvoir s'en servir et
donc éventuellement partir sont dans une
recherche d'emploi les minima sociaux je
trouve sont trop souvent présentés comme
du curatif
ou la politique alors que la politique
se voudrait orienter vers le tout emploi
alors c'est très bien nous concerne tous
nous cautionnons tout à fait tout emploi
mais les minima sociaux s'ils sont à la
bonne hauteur je reviens toujours sur le
discours de la personne permettent
justement de se mettre dans une démarche
de plein emploi
monsieur le ministre de nous réjouissons
de l'initiative que vous avez prise
récemment me semble-t-il selon moi de
septembre pour réduire le nom recours au
droit alors vous avez parlé de
territoires zéro non recours je vous
expliquerai peut-être vous en êtes en
fermant ça m'intéresse particulièrement
vous savez que nous avons lancé les
expériences mais pas ça de territoire
zéro chômeurs c'est la même dynamique
enfin je suppose que c'est la même
finalité la même finalité c'est
permettre à des personnes de repartir de
reprendre confiance en eux
voilà alors je voudrais vous
en conclusion puisqu'on nous parlons du
pacte social vous dire au niveau du
Secours Catholique la porte d'entrée de
notre PACS social
c'est pas nous qui allons voter les
augmentations des des subventions
diverses des allocations on n'est pas là
mais vous dire que pour nous le PACS
social est lié au vivre ensemble et
comment nous pouvons construire ensemble
ce vivre ensemble
le Secours catholique en 76 ans est
passé du fer pour
les personnes qui de par leur statut
social pensaient ce qui était bon pour
les personnes en situation après on
s'est ouvert avec avec mais tout en
gardant quand même les manettes pour
décider
et puis dernièrement on est en train de
se dire bien il faut qu'on passe à agir
avec
et maintenant on en est pour
bâtir ensemble
son projet
ensemble avec la personne en difficulté
et comment ça se traduit au niveau de
notre gouvernance et bien on ose puisque
c'est des prises de risque quand j'en
suis conscient on ose la présence des
personnes en difficulté au cœur de notre
gouvernance
je vais prendre deux exemples
les personnes qui sont en recherche dans
les personnes qui sont ou plutôt qui ne
sont plus en recherche d'emploi les
chômeurs de longue durée voilà je vais y
arriver et je meurs de longue durée dans
les commissions on réfléchit sur les
chômeurs de longue durée les chômeurs de
longue durée sont-ils présents au sein
de ces commissions pour dire exactement
quel est leur vécu quels sont leurs
priorités les difficultés qu'elles
rencontres comment la société les mais
au pas ou pas
sont-ils présents autre autre point
d'attention
je suis désolé
la fin de vie et ça sera intéressant que
les personnes elles-mêmes confrontées
puissent donner leur avis voilà alors je
vais pas prolonger depuis longtemps
simplement juste une petite phrase pour
faire un petit clin d'oeil à notre Pape
François qui nous invite à nous mettre
au pas des plus pauvres alors soyons
attentifs pour cheminer au pas des plus
pauvres et faire en sorte qu'on puisse
leur redonner leur dignité et leur
permet de retrouver confiance en eux
merci merci beaucoup pour pour vos
propos introductifs Hervé effectivement
on peut on peut rappeler que les
personnes qui vivent la pauvreté sont
les premières expertes de leur situation
et que et que c'est leur expertise aussi
qui peut qui peut être bénéfique pour
pour agir et trouver des réponses
pertinentes alors je clos ce premier ce
premier tour de table en donnant la
parole à Perrine Goulet voilà
particulièrement sur les questions de
d'enfance enfance en danger en France
protéger plus largement voilà l'enfance
et les familles à toi Perrine bonjour à
toutes et à tous alors je vais reprendre
ce que vient dire monsieur mon ami je
vais parler d'autres sans voix les
enfants ça fait maintenant 30 ans qu'en
France on a ratifié la Convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant
mais force est de constater que même en
France alors qu'on pourrait tous
s'enorgueillir de se dire que tous les
enfants de notre pays on leur doit
respecter c'est faux il y a encore de
nombreux droits pour ces enfants qui ne
sont pas respectés vous parliez de la
pauvreté tout à l'heure un demi million
d'enfants vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté dans notre pays
et ces inégalités destin commencent dès
le plus jeune âge quand on sait
effectivement que seulement 5% des
enfants de milieu défavorisés accèdent à
la crèche contre 22% pour les
populations les plus aisées ça commence
par là la difficulté des inégalités et
puis on continue et quand on se rend
compte un petit peu et qu'on fait le
bilan des violences faites aux enfants
dans notre pays pour moi ils sont
dramatiques
le harcèlement scolaire en moyenne deux
enfants par classe sont touchés par le
harcèlement scolaire au cours de la
scolarité on a également les violences
sexuelles dans une classe également ce
que je pense que c'est le plus simple
pour se représenter quand vous assistez
à qu'on fait une intervention de bonne
classe vous savez que devant vous il y a
entre trois et cinq enfants qui sont
victimes de violence sexuelles
sexuel donc je vous parle pas bien
entendu des autres violences dont sont
victimes ses enfants qui concourent
chaque année à ce qu'un enfant meurt
tous les trois jours sous les coups de
son environnement intrafamilial allant
c'est statistiques souvent les entends
beaucoup pour les violences faites aux
femmes mais pas pour les violences
faites aux enfants il faut que notre
pays regarde en face ces violences
faites aux enfants et effectivement il y
a une question qui est apparue qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire sur les violences
familiales vis-à-vis des enfants et bien
je suis heureuse que pour la première
fois à l'Assemblée nationale la
présidente et c'est sûrement parce que
c'est une présidente vient de créer une
délégation au droit de l'enfant à
l'Assemblée nationale 30 ans après la
ratification par la France de la
convention internationale droit de
l'enfant et en tous les cas je sais
qu'avec cette commission on va pouvoir
cette délégation va pouvoir mieux
regarder ces violences faites aux
enfants
et quand on parle violence faite aux
enfants bien souvent on est obligé de
les protéger ses enfants les protéger de
leur environnement familial il faut
savoir que dans notre pays 386 000
enfants sont mis sous la protection de
l'État et des départements notamment
sur ces 300 86000 216000 sont mis dans
des lieux en dehors de leur foyer
familial et 170000 sont accompagnés à
leur domicile par les travailleurs
sociaux des départements
mais on extrait souvent ses enfants de
leur situation familiale violente mais
on se rend compte et c'est la Défenseur
des droits qui nous l'a indiqué qu'on
les replonge parfois dans d'autres
violences dans ces établissements un
établissement sur deux est touché par
les violences intra des violences entre
enfants dans ces établissements
alors quand on sait également que c'est
une perte de chance de passer par ces
établissements puisque les statistiques
notamment du rapport de l'abbé Pierre
font un quart des jeunes de moins de 25
ans à la rue sans passer par l'aide
sociale en France quand on sait qu'une
jeune fille de 17 ans à 9 fois plus de
chances d'être enceinte quand elle est
passée par l'aide sociale à l'enfance on
voit bien que là ce qui part d'un bon
sentiment c'est-à-dire d'enlever les
enfants de leur milieu familial pour les
protéger on les remet parfois dans des
milieux qui à nouveau les protègent pas
assez et ce pour revenir sur ce que vous
disiez monsieur le ministre pour moi
c'est du à des difficultés au niveau
effectivement de l'encadrement de ses
enfants dans ces établissements et vous
l'avez très justement tous évoqué alors
pas au niveau de la protection de
l'enfance mais au niveau des autres
établissements que ce soit
établissements pour personnes une
situation de handicap ou les personnes
âgées on a un problème avec nos nos
travailleurs sociaux dans ces
établissements on a un problème votre
activité on a un problème de
reconnaissance on a un problème même de
sens du travail à ce jour et je pense
que c'est vraiment un véritable défi des
années à venir et je suis ravie que vous
en soyez convaincu aussi monsieur le
ministre et moi en tout cas ce qui
concerne la protection de l'enfance je
suis toujours outré de savoir qu'il n'y
a pas de taux d'encadrement pour ces
établissements qu'il n'y a pas de
minimum de formation pour pouvoir
encadrer ses enfants là et que c'est au
bon vouloir des départements et la
problématique des départements c'est
autant de départements autant de
politiques de protection de l'enfance
autant de politique de social et avec
des inégalités fortes dans notre pays
alors monsieur le ministre en tant
qu'effectivement ministre des
Solidarités moi je reste à votre
disposition pour avancer sur ces sujets
là je pense qu'on en a besoin on a
besoin de redonner du sens à nos
travailleurs sociaux parce que le pacte
social de notre pays ne passe que parce
qu'on a des gens qui sont capables
d'accompagner les enfants les familles
les personnes océan du les personnes
âgées les pauvres les plus fragiles ceux
qui ont aussi on en parlait tout à
l'heure des difficultés psychologiques
on a besoin de nos traverses sociaux on
a besoin d'en refaire à mon avis un
vivier fort de notre territoire donc je
pense qu'il faut vraiment qu'on agisse à
ce niveau-là et pourquoi conclure pour
aller très vite puisque j'essaie de
tenir les 4 minutes moi je pense que
l'avenir de notre pays on souhaite
lutter contre effectivement les
phénomènes d'extrême et pour moi ça
passe par les enfants on connaît la
force de persuasion des enfants
vis-à-vis de leurs parents quand c'est
par exemple au niveau environnement pour
changer certaines pratiques à la maison
alors passons par nos enfants
investissons sur nos enfants
investissons sur cette partie charnière
et sur des plus fragiles d'entre nous
pour faire société pour demain et avoir
un monde social plus juste et un pays
plus juste je vous remercie merci
Perrine pour
ces mots qui se terminent avec une note
d'espoir c'est important aussi parce que
sans ça
on agit plus alors les questions en SMS
commence à arriver n'hésitez pas si vous
en avez si vous en avez à poser je m'en
ferai le relais moi je voulais poser à à
nos intervenants en particulier monsieur
le ministre une question autour de la
prise en compte une question du coup
d'ordre un peu général sur la mais qui
que tu viens d'évoquer aussi un peu
Perrine sur la prise en compte de nos
vulnérabilités comme leviers d'action
dans nos politiques publiques et dans
notre société alors il y a des gens qui
s'y intéressent qui font des travaux
là-dessus ça reste encore à mon avis ça
gagnerait à être connu mais je voulais
reprendre une une définition de Cynthia
Fleury qui a une philosophe que vous
connaissez sans doute sur la question de
la vulnérabilité qui elle dit c'est une
vérité de la condition humaine partagée
par tous et pas uniquement par ceux qui
font l'expérience plus spécifique de la
maladie c'est certes la vulnérabilité
fragilise le sujet mais elle peut aussi
être l'occasion d'une sublimation
possible elle l'est d'ailleurs souvent
et donc elle dit la vulnérabilité invite
l'homme à inventer un étau ça produire
un geste plus soucieux de la différence
de l'autre elle fait naître chez nous
une préoccupation une attention une
qualité inédite de présence au monde et
aux autres alors Monsieur le Ministre
comment on utilise davantage nos
vulnérabilités comme un levier d'action
publique
merci beaucoup pour cette question parce
que je crois profondément dans cette
dans cette démonstration
dit peut-être avec des mots plus simples
moi l'exemple que je prends toujours
c'est la crise sanitaire la crise
sanitaire qui sont la vulnérabilité vous
voyez on s'extériorise souvent en disant
sur vulnérables les autres voilà une
personne en situation de handicap une
personne âgée en perte d'autonomie un
enfant mais c'est jamais nous une
personne en situation de précarité sauf
celle qui le vivent au quotidien et bien
ce que nous a montré la crise sanitaire
c'est finalement qu'on était tous
vulnérables et la démonstration qui a
été faite c'est que lorsque on est
touché par cette vulnérabilité
personnellement ça fait naître la
sublime la sublimation dont parle
Cynthia Fleury c'est le sentiment de
solidarité et l'action la mise en action
dans dans la solidarité donc moi je
crois profondément dans cette voilà dans
cette dialectique là pour renforcer la
cohésion sociale dans notre pays d'air
c'est pour ça que je me suis engagé dans
une association avant de revenir faire
un peu de politique parce que je crois
profondément que c'est le ciment de
notre société que chaque individu vient
il a un rôle à jouer dans notre société
pour la cohésion pour renforcer en fait
le lien social pour renforcer aussi ce
qui fait ce qui fait nations et que
c'est important qu'on cultive ça au sein
de notre société et que si on veut
vraiment voilà avoir une société et
impact social qui soit fort faut qu'on
reconnaisse aussi la valeur de ces de
ces vulnérabilités qu'on les voit pas
comme quelque chose de négatif qu'on
change aussi notre regard et toute notre
politique aujourd'hui elle vise à
changer le regard qu'on voit dans le
vulnérabilité vous le disiez tout à
l'heure monsieur le vice-président c'est
le pouvoir d'agir qu'on va voir derrière
une personne vulnérable
capable autrement pour encore une fois
des personnes en situation de handicap
la participation des personnes en
situation de précarité à l'élaboration
des politiques publiques ou à la
solution d'ailleurs qui qui va leur
permettre de sortir de cette situation
de précarité c'est le regard qu'on porte
et là je fais référence là aussi au
Conseil national de la refondation vous
savez qu'on a mis le Bien vieillir au
cœur de ce conseil national moi je crois
profondément que le sujet aujourd'hui du
vieillissement avant d'être un sujet
médico-social c'est d'abord le sujet du
regard que porte notre société sur le
vieillissement et de la place des
personnes âgées des seniors au sein de
notre de notre société et donc voilà je
vais un peu loin là-dedans mais vraiment
c'est le cœur je pense de notre Pax
social et de la solution qui doit nous
permettre de trouver des réponses à ces
difficultés
merci sur la question effectivement du
changement de regard en préparant la
table ronde je pense qu'on l'a évoqué
avec chacun individuellement des
personnes ici au Secours catholique
c'est aussi un de vos axes forts et puis
nous et lui locaux et toi aussi Perrine
sur la question de l'enfance peut-être
vous vous rajoutez Hervé quelque chose
sur très rapidement pour être dans vos
mots pour moi la vulnérabilité c'est
l'énergie
pour la solidarité c'est-à-dire c'est
parce qu'on a connu un moment donné
cette fragilité que la vulnérabilité on
s'approche quelque part un peu du
précipice et qu'on a pu réagir qu'on
retrouve les ressources pour se mettre à
disposition des autres et nous on le
voit bien dans les dans les bénévoles
que l'on recrute quels bénévolats ont
tous une histoire avec la vulnérabilité
voilà c'est je voulais simplement dire
ça c'est tout merci alors peut-être on
va prendre une tu veux rajouter un et on
prend une première question ensuite SMS
pendant que les questions arrivent juste
vraiment quelque chose de très court ça
me fait parce qu'on a tous vécu cette
question de la vulnérabilité et la force
quand on a réussi à passer au dessus de
l'épreuve ça ça amène d'ailleurs
peut-être dans un début de solution qui
est la pérégence vous le faites vous le
pratiquez au Secours catholique il y a
d'autres opportunités mais on voit bien
que quand ce sont des personnes qui
parlent de personnes la question de la
confiance elle est plus naturelle et
peut-être que là on a un début de
solution aussi pour restaurer cette
confiance et ça marche très bien
merci alors sur les questions qui
commencent à arriver de de des métiers
de l'action sociale qui a été un peu
esquissé par les uns et les autres
plusieurs questions sur le terrain les
acteurs du domicile ou des
établissements ne savent plus quoi faire
pour attirer les salariés ça a l'air bas
pénibilité multiple tant partiel comment
redonner du sens et créer les conditions
d'attractivité ont effectivement dans
tous les secteurs de l'économie et de
l'action sociale on manque de bras en
manque de main d'oeuvre mais dès lors
que ce sont les métiers de l'humain qui
sont concernés ça nous pose à tous une
vraie difficulté parce que que ce soit
dans le champ de des personnes âgées
mais aussi dans le champ de la
protection de l'enfance mais aussi dans
le champ des crèches mais aussi dans le
champ du handicap et je salue
affectueusement Geneviève Darius sec au
premier rang qui a bien pris en main le
ministère de charger des personnes
handicapées merci pour pour ton action
voilà donc comment on fait pour pour
créer une mobilisation générale sur la
question de l'attractivité de ces
métiers parce que sans toutes ces
personnes dans nos établissements c'est
la dignité de celles et ceux qui sont
concernés qui est atteintes lors Anne tu
as esquissé un petit peu des des points
nuls c'est vrai que les départements on
est au premier chef concerné aussi par
ce manque de bras dans la protection de
l'enfance chez nous dans les
Hauts-de-Seine par exemple et ben on a
200 postes ouverts non pourvu donc c'est
c'est difficile voilà les uns et les
autres si vous avez des pistes pour de
réponse
je sais pas parce que c'est le à mon
idée c'est le truc le plus difficile à
faire et c'est le défi auquel on aura
bien du mal à répondre mais pour avoir
fait de l'immersion dans les dans nos
services d'aide à domicile j'ai quand
même constaté que on a encore des gens
qui ont le feu sacré voilà qui sont pas
qui sont très heureux de s'occuper de
personnes âgées ou de personnes
handicapées d'être là au quotidien qui
qui arrive à gérer le temps contraints
qui sont des rayons de soleil dans la
vie des gens donc des gens qu'on feu
sacré il y en a encore il faut qu'on
lève les freins il faut qu'on lève les
freins et les freins ils sont évidemment
sur la rémunération ils sont sur les
questions de mobilité et ils sont sur
des questions de
d'habilitation au sens où on a des
personnes qui qui parfois s'interdisent
aussi des choses voilà il faut ta
question la confiance elle est
importante voilà les salaires mais ça
suppose qu'on
finance beaucoup beaucoup et ça j'ai pas
de planche à billes dans la cave et je
crois que
le mystère vous en avez pas non plus
donc je sais pas comment on va résoudre
cette équation là mais des salaires
suffisant pour vivre dignement et puis
de la mobilité il y a une expérience
intéressante dans le lot il me semble où
il y a où on a décidé de mettre en place
pour les aides à domicile non pas des
voitures de services mais des voitures
de fonction
il semblerait que ce soit assez décisif
quand même dans la dans la décision
voilà
et quand elles sont électriques c'est
mieux je bon je sais plus si elles le
sont ou pas mais
peut-être deux éléments enfin vous
l'avez entendu dans mon introduction
c'est vraiment quelque chose d'essentiel
et encore une fois on transformera pas
nos politiques publiques et on les
mettra pas en oeuvre sans ces femmes et
ses hommes l'attractivité des métiers
pour moi c'est deux choses c'est à la
fois les conditions de travail et donc
il y a la question des salaires mais qui
ne fait pas tout vous aurez remarqué que
le Seigneur de la santé c'était quand
même 12 milliards d'euros qui ont été
investis dans les salaires des
professionnels du soin de
l'accompagnement les professionnels
socio-éducatifs plutôt depuis cette
année donc c'est loin de faire tout
puisqu'il y a quand même une
satisfaction générale globale alors
qu'on n'a jamais mis autant d'argent
dans le dans le système certes pour
rattraper une situation pour répondre
aussi à une situation et exceptionnelle
mais voilà ça fait vraiment pas tout
derrière ces conditions de travail il y
a aussi la question de la qualité de vie
au travail voilà c'est vrai que c'est
des métiers qui sont parfois difficiles
qui sont exigeants d'un point de vue
physique moral du point de vue des
horaires aussi la conciliation de la vie
profession la vie personnelle et donc
faut vraiment qu'on travaille sur ces
sur ces questions là
l'organisation du travail aussi
spécifiquement sur sur le domicile on
est en train de regarder comment on peut
bien aussi répondre aux frustrations
liées à l'organisation du travail pour
les aides à domicile qui concourent à
l'inattractivité des métiers voilà c'est
de dire par exemple dans les plans
d'aide demain rajouter du temps qui
permettent voilà du temps qualitatif
avec les personnes qu'on accompagne à
domicile sur des personnes âgées ou des
personnes en situation de handicap en
dehors des actes techniques qu'on va
qu'on va apporter et ça c'est fait
partie des éléments à mon avis qui
peuvent améliorer et puis il y a la
question de comment on fait venir on
suscite des vocations voilà on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui on n'arrive pas à remplir
nos écoles en formation initiale qu'on a
du mal aussi à promouvoir les
transitions professionnelles vers ces
versets métiers donc on essaye vraiment
de faire feu tout bois il y a des
mesures qui vont
la semaine prochaine être présenté dans
les textes qui vont venir au Parlement
très vite notamment sur le sur le plein
emploi pour valoriser aussi les acquis
de l'expérience de professionnels qui
veulent progresser qui sont des parcours
professionnels elle est essentielle la
reconnaissance aussi des des de
l'expérience vous le disiez avec la avec
la période danse mais de l'expérience
des aidants voilà qui est extrêmement
important et attendu et donc on va
travailler sur ces parcours là en les
simplifiant aussi François Braun ce
matin parlait beaucoup de simplification
de bureaucratie bah nous aussi on a
vraiment un travail énorme à faire en la
matière et puis dernier point je reviens
sur le changement de regard il faut
qu'on parle de ces métiers de façon
positive parce que on en parle en disant
que c'est dur en disant que les
conditions de travail sont horribles etc
mais derrière ça c'est des métiers de
l'humain c'est des métiers qui ont du
sens et des métiers qui ont de l'impact
c'est des métiers qui peuvent répondre
aussi à l'envie d'agir de toute une
jeunesse aujourd'hui qui est
profondément engagée et donc il faut
qu'on arrive aussi à en parler
différemment ça donnera aussi un peu
plus envie aux gens de s'y engager
merci beaucoup per
rine gouplettement ce qu'on dit nos deux
interlocuteurs effectivement
financièrement c'est important il y a
des conventions collectives quand même
qui sont qui sont très négatives on va
dire notamment pour les domicile mais je
voulais revenir et je suis complètement
d'accord avec vous et aussi le
changement de regard et l'attractivité
de ces métiers là et le sens
je vois beaucoup à mon avis vous avez
beaucoup comme moi des enfants dans la
salle vous avez eu tout ça gérer des
enfants alors quand vous en avez deux ou
trois ça gère ils ont deux trois ans
d'écart ça va les éducateurs mettez-vous
à leur place les éducateurs qui se
retrouvent avec des groupes de 10 à 12
enfants du même âge qui sont âgés de 7
ans à 10 ans moi je leur tiens mon
chapeau comment voulez-vous qu'il fasse
un travail qui a du sens en ayant autant
d'enfants à gérer on peut amener le même
sujet sur les personnes âgées puisqu'en
fonction des établissements et en
fonction de ce que vous êtes capable de
payer parce que faut être clair les
établissements pas chers il y a un taux
d'encadrement qui est faible
établissements plus élevés il y a
souvent un taux d'encadrement qui va
avec
pour l'avoir vu dans mon département ça
c'est quand même assez vrai madame je
vois mais pour avoir quelques fait le
calcul chez moi je vous dis que ça c'est
vrai c'est pas normal c'est pas normal
on a besoin d'un autre pays d'avoir des
taux d'encadrement qui soit capable
d'accompagner les personnes de prendre
du temps le président dans la campagne a
dit qu'il fallait donner deux heures par
semaine
ose aux employés à domicile pour pouvoir
échanger avec les personnes âgées il va
falloir qu'on y arrive parce
qu'aujourd'hui effectivement pour avoir
vu beaucoup de salariés à domicile elles
sont chronométrées elles utilisent leur
propre voiture leur propre essence elles
sont payées au kilomètre au lance-pierre
c'est plus possible et c'est des métiers
on est dans une société qui va vieillir
on le sait donc c'est des métiers qu'il
faut vraiment
qu'on redore auquel il faut qu'on
redonne du sens mais bien sûr il faut de
l'argent aussi parce que ça va avec et
je pense que on dit on sait pas comment
faire mais de façon va falloir trouver
une solution
je vois pas d'autres choses à dire on
peut pas quand on éducateur avoir fait
un bac + 3 et être payé au smic c'est
pas possible avant c'est pas possible
donc il faut qu'on trouve l'argent faut
qu'on trouve des leviers il faut qu'on
trouve peut-être des économies il faut
peut-être faire moins de route et faire
un peu plus de social
merci Perrine alors sur cette question
de des métiers on est dans dans un
moment où
ou tous les secteurs on le disait manque
de bras mais pour autant il reste encore
un certain nombre de chômeurs inscrits
dans les Pôle Emploi comment est-ce
qu'on fait et là je m'adresse plutôt au
ministre aussi comment est-ce qu'on fait
pour davantage
que les connexions se fassent davantage
entre toutes les personnes qui cherchent
un emploi et tous ces pans de l'économie
sachant que ce sont des emplois de
proximité non délocalisables et vous
l'avez vous l'avez dit il y a un sujet
de représentation qu'on a de ces métiers
là mais mais pour autant il y a des gens
qui cherchent un emploi en bas de chez
eux et qui pourrait qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui marche pas dans quel frein
il faut encore lever pour pour qu'on
fasse mieux l'adéquation
il y en a plusieurs je pense qu'il y a
des questions qui sont liées à la
formation et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
que le Président de la République depuis
5 ans à autant investi dans la question
de la formation tout simplement pour ben
voilà rapprocher l'offre de la demande
que les personnes soient aussi formées
aux métiers dont on a dont on a besoin
enfin qui offre des débouchés la
question de l'accompagnement de façon de
façon générale voilà je reviens sur la
question du RSA parce que le des
bénéficiaires du RSA faut quand même
savoir qu'il y en a 50% d'entre eux qui
le sont depuis plus de 5 plus de 5 ans
ça veut dire que il y a quelque chose
qui ne fonctionne pas dans le système il
y a 20% des bénéficiaires du RSA qui ne
qui n'ont aucun accompagnement voilà et
je crois pas que la société puisse
considérer qu'elle est quitte
lorsqu'elle verse juste une prestation
sociale à une personne et que on a
besoin de renforcer cette accompagnement
et comme je vous l'ai dit moi je crois
profondément et là c'est fort aussi de
de mon expérience à la croix que la
première des dignité à offrir à offrir à
une personne qui peut travailler c'est
une activité c'est un travail et donc il
faut qu'on fasse tout pour améliorer
renforcer cet accompagnement y compris
de personnes qu'on a complètement
abandonné c'est 10 20 30 dernières
années sont les personnes qui sont les
plus éloignées du système de droit
commun les plus éloignés de l'emploi
aujourd'hui on sait qu'il y a des
expérimentations qui fonctionnent je
suis allé cette semaine rendre visite à
une association qui s'appelle
convergence qui portait entre autres par
Emmaüs Aurore et la viande et la ville
de Paris qui va justement chercher des
personnes très exclues très éloignées de
l'emploi pour et bien les accompagner de
façon globale il peut leur permettre de
d'accéder aux soins leur permettre de
les remobiliser progressivement de les
soutenir de leur trouver un logement
voilà pour lever petit à petit en fait
toutes les tous les freins qui leur
permettent d'accéder au marché de
l'emploi et je pense qu'on peut aborder
cette question je le cette façon apaisée
sans opposer économie est associable
parce que tout est lié et que on peut
voilà sans stigmatiser d'ailleurs qui
que ce soit mais on doit le faire parce
que il y a là une partie je pense de la
solution à la question que que vous avez
posé merci beaucoup Hervé Bonamy vous
vouliez réagir oui oui dans la suite
parce que j'ai rien enlevé un point
virgule je pense que la première
démarche c'est pour ces personnes là
puisque on en accompagne c'est reprendre
confiance en soi
c'est avant même de parler d'allocations
ou de choses comme ça c'est un
accompagnement humain un accompagnement
de proximité c'est là où où les
associations peuvent venir en complément
de ce que le de ce que l'État prend en
charge
et tant que la personne a pas repris
confiance et qu'elle est prête à faire
le premier pas pour se dire
je entend comme en tant que femme je
peux apporter quelque chose à la société
j'existe je recommence à vivre quelque
part et ce chemin là c'est long
c'est très long et si on a des objectifs
quantitatifs et bien c'est compliqué
d'associer les deux il faut savoir
prendre ce temps là c'est pour que la
personne puisse à nouveau dire ben je
vais oser aller travailler une heure ou
deux heures par semaine
c'est toute la démarche de territoire
zéro chômeurs on va chercher des
personnes qui sont qui sont très loin de
l'emploi et on commence pas par leur
dire vous avez travaillé 35 heures
semaine une heure ou deux heures
simplement pour retrouver ce que c'est
que la vie de l'entreprise pour
retrouver ce que c'est que répondre à
des consignes pour retrouver ce que
c'est que d'atteindre des objectifs et
un peu à la fois comme ça on arrive à en
remettre en marche donc avant de penser
des des schémas qui peuvent être frayeux
même si c'est important d'apporter à
côté toute toute la logistique et tout
mais c'est vraiment une une cause dont
on a
tous une part de responsabilité là où on
est voilà c'est ce que je voulais dire
aussi c'est pas simplement le le la
problématique du gouvernement ou des
collectivités territoriales ou locales
c'est aussi c'est aussi chaque citoyen
qui doit être sensible à ça et moi je
vous le dis monsieur le ministre et puis
chers personnes des collectivités
locales et territoriales les
associations sont là quoi des assauts
pour accompagner parce que l'avantage du
bénévole dans nos associations c'est
qu'il y en a beaucoup qui sont traités
vous en avez un exemple devant vous mais
et en même temps on gère autrement le
temps quand vous verrez quand vous y
arriverez on gère autrement le temps et
ce temps-là on peut le mettre à
disposition d'un accompagnement en
douceur d'un accompagnement
sans brusquer comme je disais tout à
l'heure au pas des plus beaux voilà
merci beaucoup pour ce complément alors
une question sur la question de la lutte
contre les violences familiales et
vis-à-vis des enfants alors une question
pour chacun d'entre vous mais en
particulier peut-être pour Perrine
Goulet qu'est-ce que comment est-ce
qu'on peut améliorer la question de la
lutte contre les violences familiales et
vise la vidéo des enfants quand on
considère que la cellule de base de la
société ça reste la famille et que et
que les formes les formes familiales ont
évolué les familles sont parfois
fragilisées en même temps voilà qui dit
frami famille fragilisée dit aussi
enfant fragilisé donc comment est-ce que
on on de quel levier on dispose
qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on a en
main pour pour améliorer cette lutte
contre les violences familiales Perrine
alors très belle question et je remercie
celui ou celle qui l'a posé pour moi
deux leviers principaux le premier c'est
vous
toutes et tous
je vous rappelle qu'il y a trois ans
nous avons voté une loi à l'initiative
de ma collègue mode petit contre les
violences éducatives ordinaires
je pense que chacun autour de vous vous
avez déjà vu quelqu'un mettre une claque
quelqu'un rabaisser son enfant par la
voix tu es nul tu sers à rien tu y
arriveras jamais je l'ai même vu moi sur
des profs avec mes enfants donc chacun
d'entre vous a les moyens de mettre fin
à des violences faites aux enfants pour
moi c'est le premier levier le deuxième
levier c'est que l'enfant est conscience
que ce qu'on lui fait n'est pas normal
et pour se faire je n'envoie qu'un et je
suis ravi parce que papédia il a
commencé à l'évoquer ces derniers jours
c'est l'école
faire de l'éducation alors on dit sexuel
c'est pour voter c'est pour violer
n'importe quoi c'est pour lutter contre
les violences sexuelles mais également à
l'école expliquer que on n'a pas le
droit de frapper un enfant mais qu'un
enfant a pas le droit d'en frapper un
autre ça commence par là aussi de ne pas
tolérer à l'école les violences faites
aux enfants et moi je suis convaincu que
ça passe également par des modules
effectivement à l'école et apprendre aux
enfants
qu'à 6 ans on n'a pas le droit de
toucher ton zizi on n'a pas le droit de
toucher ta nounette si sa famille est
dysfonctionnante elle ne lui aura pas
appris mais le savoir à 6 ans peut-être
qu'il aura été agressé sexuellement
entre 5 ans et 6 ans mais on arrêtera
plus vite le problème aujourd'hui c'est
que les enfants comprennent à peu près
que c'est interdit alors ça rajeunit ça
c'est malheureusement les effets de la
pornographie néfastes d'ailleurs mais
les enfants
prennent les choses qui sont pas normal
vers 10 12 ans
mais alors quand on a vécu
4 ans 5 ans de violences sexuelles on
s'en remet pas de la même manière que
quand on l'a vécu une fois et qu'on est
capable de dire qu'on l'a vécu tout de
suite donc je pense pour moi c'est
vraiment les deux leviers je sais pas si
mes collègues en ont d'autres et moi je
suis convaincu par ces deux-là il faut
tout un village pour élever un enfant et
chacun a son rôle à jouer mais
l'éducation nationale en priorité merci
beaucoup alors pour chacun des trois
autres intervenants aussi je prolonge la
question comment on soutient la
parentalité aussi dans cette affaire là
alors Monsieur Bonamy vous vouliez
parler comme une histoire longue avec
l'Éducation nationale et donc je me
permets de tout à fait en face avec vous
mais aussi de rejoindre les parents
c'est-à-dire que les parents soient
informés de ce qui se dit et se vit à
l'école
parce que
parfois ça c'est une belle thérapie
c'est une belle thérapie pour les
parents c'est parce que je vais dire
mais qui se sentent un petit peu
surveillés en disant attention dans le
comportement que je vais avoir parce que
il y aura une résonance au sein de la
classe voilà donc c'est ce que je
voulais ajouter
moi juste peut-être un mot c'est que il
faut impérativement qu'on continue à
investir sur là aussi ce qui a été fait
ces dernières années c'est-à-dire sur
les trois premières années de la vie
c'est là où tout se joue c'est la
politique des 1000 jours c'est là où
l'enfant va se développer c'est là où
effectivement il va apprendre beaucoup
de choses c'est là où on peut
accompagner aussi à la parentalité et
c'est là où ça le plus d'impact je pense
et donc c'est là aussi où le le projet
de service public de la petite enfance
c'est-à-dire la capacité que notre
société aura demain à offrir à chaque
famille une place d'accueil pour le
jeune enfant est essentiel là que ce
soit en crèche ou que ce soit chez les
assistantes
maternelle et bien il faut qu'on puisse
demain offrir une place pour chaque
famille chaque enfant il va falloir
recruter massivement en sachant qu'il
manque déjà 10
000 effectivement professionnels dans
les crèches aujourd'hui c'est
effectivement un sacré challenge
moi je suis d'accord pour dire que la
cellule familiale reste quand même la
base de notre société qu'il faut qu'on
la préserve je suis d'accord pour dire
que les parents restent les premiers
éducateurs des enfants aussi donc
encore une fois il faut qu'on soit non
pas dans la réparation mais dans la
prévention au maximum donc bien sûr du
soutien la parentalité aujourd'hui on
peut dire que beaucoup d'échelons en
font les communes enfin le bloc local
commune intercommunalité et les
départements bien sûr peut-être qu'il
faut d'ailleurs qu'on investisse un tout
petit peu plus et tout ça ça doit se
faire au partenariat en fait à chaque
fois il faut arriver à mailler le
territoire s'assurer que tout est
couvert la CAF est un partenaire
institutionnel 4.0 en plus la plupart du
temps sur lequel on peut s'appuyer ils
ont vraiment une dynamique très
territoriale ce qu'il faut pas que ça
soit pensé c'est que ces sujets là il
faut pas les penser au plus enfin bien
sûr qu'il faut que le gouvernement s'en
saisisse mais la mise en oeuvre peut pas
être pensée au sommet des tailles il
faut vraiment que ce soit mis en place
sur les territoires à l'Islande bassin
de vie en fonction des réalités locales
et plus on soutiendra ça parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de situations qui pourraient ne
pas dégénérer et donc ne pas aboutir à
un placement une judiciarisation etc
voilà si on a pu prévenir et on avait
enfin dans le département de l'Eure on a
mis en place des expérimentations pour
prévenir ces situations malheureusement
on s'est retrouvé avec le contact
sanitaire nos services complètement
embolisés par les informations
préoccupantes à traiter et donc nos
travailleurs sociaux n'ont pas pu mettre
en oeuvre encore toutes ces mesures de
prévention avec un sujet qui est quand
même majeur qui est la PMI parce qu'on a
un outil fantastique qui est la
Protection Maternelle Infantile dans nos
départements mais qui a une image
aujourd'hui enfin véhicule et vécu par
nos concitoyens qui est juste désastreux
c'est à dire que la PMI peut plus vrai
d'abord parce que dès qu'on voit
quelqu'un de la PMI il y a plein de gens
ouh là là en fait on va me les retirer
mes enfants donc ils veulent pas et on
n'arrive pas à enfin je sais pas comment
on va faire mais il faut qu'on change
cette dynamique là et qu'on se redise
que la PMI est un lieu de mixité aussi
et que ceux qui en ont le plus ce qui
n'en n'ont pas beaucoup besoin peut-être
qu'il apparemment on aurait pas besoin
en fait on a aussi besoin ça rejoint nos
vulnérabilité jeune maman je sais pas
voilà moi jeune maman je suis toute
jeune maman je suis allée à la PMI bien
sûr moi aussi vous vouliez rajouter je
voulais juste faire une petite insiste
parce qu'on parle de la famille et qu'on
parle aussi de du pacte social et de
notre système de protection sociale vous
savez qu'il est fondé sur cette cellule
familiale qui est la première brique la
base en fait de notre résilience
individuelle et collective c'est là où
tout se construit c'est là où on le fait
et juste je voudrais attirer votre
attention sur un sujet qui à mon sens
est important parce qu'on y pense pas
suffisamment c'est que notre système de
protection sociale il est familiarisé
c'est à dire que les appuis d'abord sur
cette solidarité familiale c'est
extrêmement important vous savez qu'on a
des conjugué la hache ça a été l'une des
premières mesures de cette mandature ça
fait couler beaucoup d'encre dans la
mandature précédente parce que je pense
que à juste titre la représentation
nationale voulait justement protéger ce
système familial et donc on a apporté là
une mesure qui est une avancée et un
progrès majeur de dignité aussi pour les
personnes en situation de handicap mais
il faudrait pas que ce soit une
ouverture justement pour détricoter le
reste de notre système de protection
sociale qui est familialisé et donc il
est précieux il faut le protéger il faut
le conserver cache pas que du côté de
l'extrême gauche j'ai déjà eu des des
attaques dès le début de cette mandature
justement prenant exemple sur la
question de la décongélisation de de la
hache mais voilà je mets ça dans le
débat aussi pour que chacun ait bien
conscience que ce système il repose sur
sur la famille et que c'est important de
le protéger
merci beaucoup oui vous pouvez
l'applaudir tout à fait ici au modem les
questions familiales nous sont chères
alors il reste quelques minutes et donc
n'hésitez pas si vous avez d'autres
questions une question est venue et qui
fait suite effectivement
aux enjeux voilà de de d'attractivité
des métiers aussi quelle est la
perspective pour le versement de la
prime Ségur à l'ensemble des personnels
du secteur médico-social injustice
actuel pour les personnes à
l'administratives techniques et généraux
alors pour pour illustrer la question
par exemple donc je suis en charge de la
protection de l'enfance dans mon
département et à la Cité de l'enfance du
Plessis-Robinson qui vient de nous
établissements départementaux et bien
les maîtresses de maison m'avaient
interpellé pour me dire bah nous
maîtresse de maison on est vrai un
rouage essentiel dans la vie d'une d'une
structure de protection de l'enfance
parce qu'on contribue au bien-être on
contribue au fait qu'il mange bien on
contribue au fait qu'ils sont dans un
cadre chaleureux bienveillant
structurant en revanche on n'est pas
concerné par cette rime et donc
ce sentiment un peu de voilà de de
d'inégalité de rupture alors comme le
disait Anne voilà il y a pas de planche
à billets dans la cave mais comment on
fait pour que voilà ce ce sentiment en
tout cas ce sentiment de rupture
d'égalité des personnels
soient
qu'on puisse voilà ce qu'il soit atténué
qu'on puisse remédier à ça alors pas de
question piège mais préalable à tout ce
que je vais dire encore une fois la
traque dans l'attractivité des métiers
il y a un vrai sujet de salaire et
effectivement ce sont des professions
qui sont très mal rémunérés de façon de
façon générale donc il y a un sujet de
salaire auquel il faut répondre et
particulièrement pour ces personnes qui
n'ont pas été concernées par par le
Ségur il faut qu'on y apporte une
réponse ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point j'ai je me suis exprimé
cette semaine sur ce sujet ça a créé
beaucoup de remous parce que j'ai dit il
n'y aura pas de 183 euros pour les
personnels administratifs techniques et
généraux
tu veux pas dire encore une fois qu'il
faut pas qu'il soit augmenté mais j'ai
renvoyé la responsabilité de tes
augmentations aux employeurs pourquoi
parce que je pense que maintenant il est
temps de sortir de la logique Ségur la
logique Ségur elle a été conçue pour
apporter une réponse à une situation
exceptionnelle liée encore une fois un
problème d'attractivité long qui a connu
une crise majeure à l'occasion de de la
pandémie de covid et à laquelle on a
souhaité répondre et donc on a
privilégié on a fait un choix
effectivement de
d'augmenter via cette prime les salaires
des soignants des personnels
socio-éducatifs qu'on a élargi petit à
petit mais dans une méthodologie qui à
mon avis ne faut surtout jamais
reproduire parce que elle a créé des
inégalités dans les filières entre
métiers entre secteur etc dont on voit
bien qu'on n'arrive pas à sortir
aujourd'hui et donc moi est-ce que je
propose au secteur c'est qu'on tourne la
page du secteur et qu'on aborde
effectivement de façon globale la
question de l'attractivité des métiers
et répondent dans un système où chacun
retrouve sa place où l'État un rôle à
jouer ou les collectivités ou un rôle à
jouer ou les employeurs ont un rôle à
jouer où les syndicats les représentants
du personnel ont un rôle à jouer parce
que là ça fait deux ans en fait qu'on se
tourne systématiquement vers l'état en
disant il y a un problème de salaire on
a besoin d'argent il faut donner 183
euros à tout le monde et donc je pense
qu'il faut qu'on revienne dans une
dynamique de dialogue social classique
qui va viser à aborder cette question de
l'attractivité des métiers de façon
large aujourd'hui il y a des
négociations salariales qui sont
engagées sur chacune des filières je
viens d'ouvrir celles cette enfin il y a
deux jours celle sur la filière petite
enfance qui n'avait pas été non plus
revalorisée et non pas avec une approche
figure mais avec une approche classique
et donc renvoyer au dialogue social
cette question des salaires l'état il
viendra évidemment financer les choses
mais il faut vraiment que chacun encore
une fois
reprennent sa place dans ce dans ce dis
actif là et puis pour ce qui concerne le
secteur associatif vous savez peut-être
désolé c'est un peu technique il y a
aujourd'hui un projet qui va viser à
répondre structurellement à cette
question qui a création d'une convention
collective unique de branche dire que
demain tous les salariés du secteur non
lucratifs qui travaillent dans les
métiers du soin de l'accompagnement
socio-éducatif etc et bien il répondront
au même au même régime conventionnel ce
qui permettrait d'éviter à la fois des
concurrences malsaines entre opérateurs
d'un même secteur on n'est pas là quand
on est associatif on n'a pas
spécialement envie de faire du dumping
social pour attirer des collaborateurs
chez soi ou
équilibrer des modèles économiques qui
sont qui sont tendus et surtout pour que
ce secteur il pèse plus fortement et que
l'ensemble des acteurs qui ont un
piloter économiquement ce secteur puisse
le faire de façon aussi plus simple donc
voilà donc il y a vraiment
c'est une question à laquelle on peut
pas répondre simplement mais simplement
vraiment moi ce que je dis c'est sortons
de cette logique c'est dur tournant la
page de Ségur et rentrons dans des
négociations salariales plus classiques
qui existait qui préexistait avant 2020
merci pour votre réponse très claire
alors on arrive quasiment au terme de
notre de nos échanges et du temps qui
nous est imparti il y avait une dernière
question
de la salle autant de gens dans la rue
comment les faire pour les en sortir
tous alors c'est une grande question qui
nécessiterait de prendre beaucoup de
temps pour y répondre voilà mais qu'on a
qu'on a vu en effet le président Macron
je pense que c'était au début de son
premier mandat avait parlé du fait que
il se fixait pour objectif de qu'il n'y
en ait plus du tout on voit bien à quel
point c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que
cela on s'impose la question de
l'hébergement d'urgence ça pose la
question du parcours résidentiel ça pose
tout un tas de d'autres sujets
sous-jacents voilà je sais pas si ça
inspire un un mot de
effectivement une question complexe ça
va inspire deux choses si moi ça la
question de la connaissance de ces
personnes en fait mais comme
l'équivalable aussi pour la connaissance
de nos bénéficiaires du RSA de voilà on
finalement on a assez peu de données je
dis pas qu'il faut tout gérer par la
donnée mais quand même ça nous
permettrait parfois de de nous rendre
compte de la réalité des parcours et de
piloter du coup des politiques publiques
qui sont quand même importantes donc il
y a la question de la donnée et avec la
responsabilité qui est la nôtre de ne
pas tout faire en passant par la donnée
et d'être capable de vivre les choses et
de les appréhender à hauteur d'homme
l'autre chose c'est qu'il y a une
politique publique qui est menée en
France qui est très méconnu mais
peut-être parce qu'elle l'est pas menée
totalement
dans sa plus pure philosophique qui est
le droit au logement enfin le logement
pour tous logements d'abord voilà je
cherchais le terme exact la politique du
logement d'abord qui est une
expérimentation des pays anglo en
particulier aux États-Unis ou au Québec
enfin mérite du Nord sur le avec ce pari
que si on veut commencer à remettre une
personne à flou il faut d'abord qu'elle
ait une un logement un toit au-dessus de
sa tête la différence alors il y a eu
des expérimentations dans certains
territoires en France notamment à
Marseille qui ont très bien fonctionné
sachant que quand on met cette personne
sous un toit on l'accompagne aussi avec
énormément d'intensité pour retrouver le
chemin de l'estime de soi de et un jour
peut-être de l'activité etc etc
moi ce que je regrette aujourd'hui mais
je sais pas si on y arrivera en France
c'est que ce dispositif là
on ne mène pas cette philosophie
jusqu'au bout c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui l'état nous demande de
faire beaucoup excusez-moi c'est un peu
technique d'intermédiation locative en
fait on veut faire du logement d'abord
sans avoir toute l'hingénierie
c'est-à-dire tous les travailleurs
sociaux qui permettent de se donner du
temps de donner du temps à aux personnes
qui sont à la rue ou qui sont grande
exclusion et donc le temps et
l'intensité d'accompagnement merci
beaucoup alors je vois que
Jean-Christophe qu'on voulait réagir à
ce que tu disais et ce sera du coup le
mot de conclusion ensuite donc je vous
laisse répondre à la question et et
avoir quelques mois de conclusion voilà
on a abordé beaucoup de sujets on n'aura
pas fait effet le tour de la question
aujourd'hui mais ça nous a permis
d'esquisser un certain nombre de pistes
alors Jean-Christophe je vous laisse la
parole c'est dur de répondre à cette
question en conclusion parce qu'elle est
vraiment complexe et je vais vous faire
un aveu c'est à dire que en 11 ans de
Croix-Rouge j'ai toujours pas je sais
toujours pas comment y répondre c'est à
dire que je sais une chose c'est que
c'est pas possible enfin en tout cas à
qui la conviction profonde que voilà
faire la promesse que on va sortir tout
le monde de la rue c'est pas possible
parce que c'est compliqué et parce que
surtout je sais même pas sûr que ce soit
souhaitable c'est à dire que ça pousse
quand même des questions aussi de
liberté individuelle de voilà on peut
faire clairement mieux c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui il faut quand même avoir
conscience qu'il énormément de personnes
qui sont à la rue qui le souhaitent pas
enfin voilà des enfants des femmes des
familles des gens qui ont encore besoin
et qu'on doit accompagner et protéger et
voilà j'étais hier à Marseille voilà il
y a des mineurs à la compagnie à la rue
etc enfin c'est extrêmement extrêmement
compliqué mais que pour ceux qui le sont
depuis très longtemps qui vivent à la
rue il y a sans doute aussi d'autres
questions qu'il faut qu'on affronte
notamment celle de la question de la
santé mentale qui est un tabou sur ce
sur ce sur ce sujet là quand on connaît
bien ses publics voilà et puis dernier
point enfin c'est ce que vous avez dit
il faut tout simplement qu'on s'en
occupe c'est à dire que il faut qu'on
voit qu'on prête attention à toutes ces
personnes aussi qui sont à l'abri et que
on ne s'y habitue pas qu'on continue à
rester indigné et qu'on ne se résigne
pas même si je vous ai dit que la
conviction qu'on y arriverait pas qu'on
ne toutefois on ne s'y résigne pas c'est
un paradoxe mais c'est comme ça et je
pense que c'est extrêmement important et
puis en conclusion voilà pour moi c'est
un mot de d'optimisme de quelque chose
de positif je pense que voilà on est
tous là des personnes extrêmement
engagées c'est important qu'on garde
aussi ce regard positif et optimiste sur
des sujets qui sont pas forcément facile
et simple à aborder et je crois que
c'est aussi le début d'une réponse et
d'une solution merci beaucoup monsieur
le ministre continuons à nous mettre au
pas des pauvres pour rebâtir notre pacte
social et oui je vois que vous avez une
question madame on pourra la prendre en
aparté parce que le temps est bref mais
merci
et bien on va y répondre juste après si
vous voulez entre nous merci beaucoup à
toutes et à tous c'est l'heure du
déjeuner donc bon appétit et à bientôt